ما زالت اغنيه النجم شاكيرا متصدر الاخبار
والمنصات ومازالت الترند رقم واحد على
يوتيوب ومشاهده وصلت ل 132 مليون مشاهده
وطبعا احنا بنتكلم عن الاغنيه اللي وجهتها
شاكيرا بشكل غير مباشر لحبيبها السابق
جيران بيكي ورمت فيه كلام كثير على
انفصالهم القصه المتداوله لكلنا خلاص
سمعناها انه خانها مع بنت عمرها 22 سنه
والان مصاحبها لهذه البنت شاكيرا نزلت
الاغنيه الناريه ومن بعدها شفنا حرب
التصريحات مو بس بينها وبين لا كمان دخلت
الشركات مثل كاسيو ورينو عندهم سياره اللي
هي تونجو واللي شبهها فيهم شاكيرا حبيبتي
الجديده بيكي هذا غير طبعا كمان
في الموضوع كمان الجديد اللي راح اتكلم
فيه وهو يبدو انه فيه جانب مضيء من قصه
شاكيرا الحزينه ونجاح يمكن يعزيها تخيل
الاربعه ايام الماضيه بس شاكيرا ربحت من
الاغنيه الجديده مليونين ونصف دولار بحسب
بيانات نشرات الفيزيون اسباني
فكيره ربحت مليون و200,000 من سماء الناس
للاغنيه عبر ابل واكثر من نص مليون من
يوتيوب ومثلهم من امازون هذا غير
360,000 من سبوتفاي وعلى فكره هذه ثالث
اغنيه بتترحها شاكيرا من وقت الانفصال عن
بيكي وموضوعها الخيانه والانفصال وهذول بس
بحسب بيانات التلفزيون الاسباني الان
مجموعه ارباحهم يعني 15 مليون دولار الله
يبارك لا صراحه حقيقه وطبعا ما ننسى كمان
انه بيكي ربح هو ايضا بعد عقد رعايه كاسيو
يعني ثنائي صراحه دروس في فن تحويل الماسي
لمكاسب
[موسيقى]